I begin to sing of IV crown Dionysus the
loud crying God
splendid son of Zeus and glorious Emily
the rich head nymphs receives him in
their bosom from the Lord he's father
and fostered and nurtured him carefully
in the Dells of nyssa whereby the will
of his father he grew up in a
sweet-smelling cave being reckoned among
the Immortals one of the few Olympians
that features in a host of stories and
seems to be ever-present in the
background in some shape or form is
Dionysus I got that I'm sure as a
favorite of many he was seen as the god
of wine pleasure festivity vegetation
madness and wild frenzy and out of all
of the gods in Greek mythology Dionysus
appears to be one of the most fun to be
around
unless you're King but we'll get to that
soon there are some of you who may be
more familiar with his Roman iteration
barkas who is almost identical to
Dionysus with a few different stories
here and there with all of that being
said Dionysus is perhaps one of the most
unique gods that we encounter in Greek
mythology a God given birth to another
God is fairly common a mortal woman
given birth to a demigod is wasn't
something we encounter quite often but a
mortal woman giving birth to a fully
fledged God was unheard of
that is until Dionysus the stories
centered around a mortal woman semele
who was a priestess of zeus now in the
form of an eagle zeus observed a Semele
slaughtered a bull at his altar and then
swam in a nearby river to wash away the
blood from that moment on Zeus was
instantly captivated and he would visit
the priestess several more times before
she eventually fell pregnant with his
child as a gift to the mother of his
child Zeus wore an oath from the River
Styx to grants Emily anything she
desired having learnt of this affair
Zeus's wife Hera was extremely jealous
of the pregnancy and decided that she
would once again intervene she appeared
to the young priestess as an old crone
and began to plant the seeds of doubt a
question induces divinity to the point
was suddenly no longer believed the
father of her child was Zeus but merely
an imposter when Zeus eventually
returned to semele she demanded to see
him in his true form to prove his
divinity
Zeus refused Cemil Eze request several
times
furthermore to was to see a God in their
true form they would immediately burst
into flames
however Zeus didn't know that he would
eventually have to grants Emily's
request because of the oath he made when
he did eventually appear to Semele just
as he feared she was consumed by fire
and the only thing that Zeus could
rescue was the unborn child which he did
by sewing him into his own thigh a few
months later a boy was born and that boy
was Dionysus many would then refer to
the boy as the twice-born referring to
the premature birth of his mother when
she burst into flames and then later his
actual birth from Zeus
after he was born Dionysus would be
raised by the satyr sight leanness and
the nymphs of Mount Nyssa Salinas
himself was a very old deity who was
heavily associated of winemaking and
drunkenness so naturally these two
became drinking partners and we can
definitely see that Silas may have had
quite a large influence in shaping
Dionysus into the God that he would
become there are definitely a host of
different stories that attempt to
explain the birth of Dionysus but this
is the one I found most interesting now
if there's one thing that we've learned
about the goddess Hera it's that she's
rather persistent after some time with
Selena's Dionysus was then entrusted to
his aunt you know the sister of Semele
when Hera lot of the boys location she
was furious that he had survived she
drove in oh and her husband mad causing
them to kill their own children and then
each other
Dionysus remained unharmed but now with
no Guardians he would have to remain
with Salinas for several more years it's
very common for Dionysus to be depicted
in two different ways either as a young
long-haired man of quite a feminine look
or an elder bearded God were much more
masculine persona now as the poem at the
start of the video may have suggested
Dionysus was often seen wearing a crown
made of ivy holding a pine cone staff
and being accompanied by several say
tears there have been several paintings
and mosaics of Dionysus been accompanied
by a leopard which was one of his sacred
animals the others been a serpent in a
ball Dionysus been a God of vegetation
and wine Minda there were several plants
that he considers sacred these of course
being the grapevine bindweed
and IV when Dionysus was still a young
boy being raised by the nymphs of Mount
Nyssa he was attacked by the king of
Thrace
like Lagos when they attempted to flee
the King took his axe and struck down
the nymph that was responsible for nurse
in Dionysus protected by the rest of the
nymphs they lept into the sea well they
would be given refuge but they got a
status the mother of Achilles after such
an attack on one of the sons of Zeus
like August was driven into a state of
madness as a punishment where he would
kill his own wife in the Sun he then
took his axe and chopped off his own
feet before eventually killing himself
as gruesome as that fate may sound there
are many other variations regarding how
the king was punished another story he
was wrapped in strangling vines and then
taken to the underworld where he would
be tormented for eternity there is a
retelling of this story where Dionysus
traveled to Thrace when he was grown
teaching the people the art of wine
makin like August being angered at the
drunken mess his people had become
attacked Dionysus and was killed as a
result but like August wouldn't be the
only king that Dionysus had some trouble
with when Pentheus became the king of
Thebes the first thing he did was ban
the worship of Dionysus who also
happened to be his cousin Dionysus of
course did not take too kindly to this
and so he caused the women of Thebes so
into a frenzy of anger and sexual
activity
Pentheus eventually captured Dionysus
assuming he was just the follow of the
God and imprisoned him however Dionysus
was able to convince the king to dress
as a woman and travel to mount cithaeron
to see what had happened to his women
once he had arrived
Pentheus climbed the tallest tree he
could find in order to see what the
women were doing in Nomad and state the
woman mistook the king for wild-animal
pulling him off the tree and tearing him
apart limb from limb ironically the
first of these women to attack Pentheus
was his own mother who only realized
what she had done upon returning to the
city so if there's one thing that we've
learned from these two stories if you're
a king who decides to anger Dionysus
it's probably the last thing that you
ever do some of you may remember in my
video on her Festus that when he was
summoned by Zeus to Olympus he declined
and none of the other gods could
convince him to change his mind
it was then Dionysus who got her Festus
so drunk that he was able to put him on
the back of a donkey and escort him to
his father now when it comes to women
it's fairly reasonable to assume that
Dionysus had several lovers with him
essentially being the party and a more
Greek mythology but he did choose to
marry one
after he killed the Minotaur Theseus
self from Crete were the two daughters
of King Minos Theseus eventually decided
that he no longer wished to marry
Ariadne and so he abandoned her on the
island of Naxos where she would be found
by Dionysus who fell in love of the
princess and decided that she would be
the woman he would marry in their union
the two had many children
but ariadne's life wasn't exactly the
easiest officer she gave birth of
Dionysus children soon after giving
birth Ariadne would be killed either by
the goddess Artemis or the hero Perseus
but she wouldn't remain in the
underworld for long which does lead us
to our next story after losing his wife
Dionysus traveled to the underworld
where he would face both Thanatos and
Hades convincing them both to allow him
to bring back Ariadne and his mother
Semele taking them both to Olympus where
they were granted immortality it was
actually later believed that Dionysus
was one of the few Olympians with the
power to bring back to see some mortals
from the underworld and restored him to
life when Dionysus was looking for
Ariadne and his mother in the underworld
he came across a shepherd known as
palamas who helped guide Dionysus and as
a reward the shepherd only wished
Dionysus to be his lover
sadly the shepherd died before Dionysus
could honor his pledge so in order to
keep his promise he fashioned a phallus
from an olive branch and placed it on
the Shepherd's tomb I'm not exactly sure
how a penis shaped Olive Branch meant
that he kept his promise but I guess you
have to give it to Dionysus for
creativity on this one when he was
traveling through the Aegean Sea and
Dionysus was captured by a group of
pirates who attempted to sell him into
slavery and this point Dionysus was
still fairly young but he took his staff
and he was able to transform most of
these pirates into dolphins in this
particular Roman mosaic it's fairly
difficult to see Dionysus because of the
damage that occurred over the years but
we do see the pirates jump in overboard
as they're being transformed we also see
some of the nymphs that were raised in
Dionysus along with a very plump look in
Selenas the final story we'll be
covering is the story of King Midas
when Dionysus and silliness were
drinking in Midas's Kingdom the two
overindulged and became separated when
king midas found salinas he offered him
his hospitality and sent him back to
Dionysus out of gratitude
Dionysus offered the king any wish of
his choice against the gods best advice
Midas requested to be able to turn
anything into gold
when - no longer wanted the gift it was
Dionysus to help the
in return everything he touched back to
normal Dionysius is one of the most
respected and valued God's in the entire
Greek pantheon many saw him as some kind
of Roman hero because he did spend most
of his life travelling teaching the art
of winemaking helping those in need and
just overall having a great time as
Dionysus traveled his cult following
only grew larger and larger which is why
there is so much classical art devoted
towards the God I'm sure there's a ton
of stuff that I haven't mentioned so if
there's anything about Dionysus you'd
like to share with me then please do
some of the comments below so if you are
new to the channel we just haven't been
receiving notifications lately then
you've probably heard this a lot from
other youtubers but if you hit that
notification bell and there's a chance
YouTube would notify you I don't really
know anymore the best way for you guys
to keep updated and make sure you never
miss a video is to go over to Twitter
and follow me there at miss explained
I'll leave a link in the description in
the comments for you guys to click on we
have recently hit 200,000 subscribers so
I'd like to thank all of you guys for
continually supporting the channel as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained and I'll see you guys
in the next video that is if you do get
notified
[Music]